well vaccinations are an important part
of public health and some medical
experts believe it is important to build
a community of immunity take a look
taking care of our own health also
protects the people around us it's
especially important for vaccinations to
occur in our kids
firstly because it really contributes to
what's called a community of immunity
the more people we get in the u.s
vaccinated against say covenant 19 or
the flu it's less likely that these
viruses can spread or even cause
variants that can cause more harm as a
family physician dr carl lambert hears
the concerns about vaccines he assures
patients that the data is very strong we
know that our current vaccines that are
out they've shown to be over 90
effective in preventing hospitalization
and severe consequences from covet 19
infections even in our children coming
to the family doctor it's a safe space
to land we want to hear all those
questions and concerns and information
you're hearing so that we can work
together to make sense of it there's a
lot of information and really our job
and duty is to stay up to date with
those things so that we can help you to
make the best decisions for you and your
family talk to your family physician and
also find great resources at
familydoctor.org
vaccines